(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Bom, acabamos de explicar na aula 1 o
que é o contrato de legislação fiduciária, que
é a modalidade de contrato que leva o
maior número de imóveis a leilão extrajudicial.
São os chamados popularmente dos leilões dos bancos.
Então, a gente viu no final da aula
que uma vez que o credor consolida a
propriedade em seu nome, ele obrigatoriamente vai ter
que realizar leilão para tentar vender aquele imóvel.
A lei estipula que o credor deve tentar
fazer dois leilões para tentar vender aquele imóvel.
O segundo leilão só acontece se não houver
arrematante no primeiro leilão.
Então, vamos estudar agora os requisitos para o
primeiro leilão.
O primeiro leilão deve acontecer 30 dias após
a data do registro da consolidação da propriedade.
A gente viu, então, que uma vez que
o devedor é notificado para purgar a mora,
ou seja, para pagar aquilo que ele está
devendo, e não faz em 15 dias, o
credor vai consolidar a propriedade.
Essa consolidação da propriedade, obrigatoriamente, deve ficar registrada
na matrícula do imóvel.
Então, a partir do prazo que o cartório
registra a consolidação da propriedade em nome do
credor na matrícula daquele determinado imóvel, começa esse
prazo de 30 dias para que o leilão
aconteça.
Esse primeiro leilão vai acontecer com o valor
que foi estipulado no próprio contrato de alienação
fiduciária para caso um leilão acontecesse.
Então, vamos lá.
Esse contrato de alienação fiduciária tem vários pequenos
requisitos.
Entre um dos requisitos desse contrato está justamente
colocar um valor para que aquele imóvel seja
levado a leilão no caso do devedor não
pagar o que ele deve ao credor fiduciário.
Então, o contrato vai estipular um valor X
para que aquele imóvel seja levado a leilão.
Esse contrato, além do valor, vai estipular também
a forma de correção daquele valor.
Porque vamos supor que um valor de R
$100 mil em 2010 não pode ser usado
de forma bruta em 2020.
Porque esses R$100 mil em 2020 não
vão valer a mesma coisa que valiam em
2010.
Então, esses R$100 mil que o contrato
estipulou em 2010 vai passar por uma correção
para atualizar aquele valor para que aquele valor
possa ser usado em 2020, se um leilão
acontecesse em 2020.
Todo contrato, então, de alegação fiduciária vai estipular
um valor para que o contrato possa ser
alienado em leilão e a forma de correção
com esse valor.
Então, a regra é que vai ser usado
o valor que o próprio contrato de alegação
fiduciária estipulou para o caso um leilão acontecesse.
Mas, a lei também coloca uma exceção à
utilização desse valor que o próprio contrato estipula.
E qual é?
A lei diz que deve ser usado o
valor do ITBI, caso o ITBI seja maior
do que o valor do contrato.
E o que é esse valor do ITBI?
É o que a gente chama de valor
venal.
O ITBI é um imposto municipal que incide
na transação de bem imóvel entre pessoas vivas.
Só título de curiosidade, se fosse a transferência
de um bem imóvel de uma pessoa que
já faleceu, o imposto seria o ITCMD e
não o ITBI.
Então, o ITBI incide na transmissão de propriedades
de bens imóveis entre pessoas vivas.
E as prefeituras estipulam o chamado valor venal.
O que é isso?
A prefeitura não vai calcular o valor de
um imóvel a cada transação que ela ocorra.
Ela coloca já um valor fixo naquele imóvel
e ela vai determinar esse valor de acordo
com o bairro que aquele imóvel está situado,
de acordo com o tamanho da propriedade daquele
imóvel.
Imóveis maiores tem, obviamente, o valor venal mais
alto.
E ela vai deixar aquele valor registrado na
prefeitura.
Então, quando você vende um imóvel, a prefeitura
quer te cobrar o ITBI naquele valor venal.
Aquele valor foi estipulado para caso acontecesse uma
transferência de um bem imóvel entre pessoas vivas.
Então, aquele valor deve ser respeitado.
O que acontece na maioria dos casos?
A prefeitura coloca o valor venal e se
a transferência da propriedade imóvel for por um
valor maior do que aquele valor venal, você
vai utilizar o valor maior para recolher o
imposto.
Se o valor da transação for menor do
que o valor venal, a prefeitura vai te
cobrar o imposto pelo valor venal daquele imóvel.
Então, para o primeiro leilão, vai ter que
ser observado qual é o valor maior.
Se é o valor do próprio contrato de
agravação fiduciária, que vai sofrer a correção até
a data do leilão, ou se é o
valor venal atribuído para a prefeitura para o
caso de transação de bens imóveis entre pessoas
vivas.
Então, se o valor venal for maior do
que o valor do contrato de agravação fiduciária,
esse valor venal vai ser usado no primeiro
leilão.
E aqui uma pequena observação.
Apesar dali falarem primeiro leilão e segundo leilão
para leilão ex-credencial, popularmente os leiloeiros também
chamam de primeira e segunda praça.
Por quê?
Porque essa denominação de primeira e segunda praça
é o que ocorre nos leilões judiciais, como
a gente já explicou no módulo 1.
Então, para não gerar maior confusão nas pessoas
que estão interessadas em arrematar um imóvel, os
leiloeiros costumam chamar o primeiro leilão de primeira
praça e o segundo leilão de segunda praça.
Não há nada de errado nisso, isso não
é motivo nenhum para questionar a realização de
um leilão.
Então, recapitulando essa informação, a primeira praça acontecerá
até 30 dias depois da consolidação da propriedade
no nome do credor.
Essa consolidação necessariamente vai estar registrada na matrícula
daquele bem e ela terá como valor mínimo
para lance o valor que o próprio contrato
de agravação fiduciária estipulou para caso acontecesse um
leilão, ou o valor venal atribuído pela prefeitura
onde aquele imóvel está localizado.
O que for maior, se for maior o
valor venal vai ser utilizado o valor venal,
se for maior o valor do contrato vai
ser utilizado o valor do contrato de agravação
fiduciária.
Esse valor, lembrando então, é o valor mínimo
do primeiro leilão, também chamado de primeira praça.
Os lances vão incidir a partir desse mínimo.
Caso o imóvel não seja arrematado em um
primeiro leilão, o imóvel seguirá automaticamente para o
segundo leilão, também chamado de segunda praça pelos
leiloeiros.
Esse segundo leilão deve ser realizado nos 15
dias seguintes do primeiro leilão e ele terá
outra forma de valor.
A gente falou que o valor da primeira
praça é o valor estipulado no contrato de
agravação fiduciária ou o valor venal do imóvel
atribuído pela prefeitura, o que for maior.
Na segunda praça, o imóvel terá como valor
mínimo o valor das dívidas mais encargos.
Então, o valor mínimo da segunda praça vai
ser o valor das dívidas mais encargos.
Normalmente, no segundo leilão, o imóvel vai por
um preço abaixo do valor do primeiro leilão.
Porque o valor do primeiro leilão, que como
a gente já falou, é o valor do
contrato de agravação fiduciária ou o valor venal,
ele tende a ficar muito próximo ao valor
de mercado daquele bem.
Então, em segunda praça, que vai pelas dívidas
mais encargos, é normal que o valor da
dívida mais os encargos que se dão sobre
aquela dívida seja menor do que o valor
de mercado daquele bem.
Então, o imóvel vai ser oferecido com os
descontos, que vai ser o percentual entre o
valor das dívidas mais os encargos e o
valor do contrato de agravação fiduciária, que é
próximo ao valor de mercado.
Mas pode acontecer, em alguns casos, que o
valor do segundo leilão, da segunda praça, seja
maior do que o valor do próprio primeiro
leilão.
Porque o valor das dívidas mais o valor
dos encargos vai ultrapassar o valor que, efetivamente,
aquele bem vale, o valor que ficou estipulado
em contrato de agravação fiduciária para que aquele
imóvel fosse levado em primeiro leilão.
Então, o que vai acontecer?
Obviamente, esse imóvel que foi levado em segundo
leilão por um preço maior do que o
primeiro leilão, ele não vai ser arrematado.
E tudo bem, caso ele não seja arrematado
em primeiro ou segundo leilão, a gente já
vai estudar o que vai acontecer.
Mas vamos lá.
Então, vamos lá.
Quais são os requisitos para que ocorra o
primeiro e o segundo leilão?
O primeiro requisito é a necessidade expressa de
que o devedor seja notificado da data do
primeiro e do segundo leilão.
Por que é obrigatório que o devedor seja
notificado da data do primeiro e do segundo
leilão?
Porque na data da consolidação da propriedade, até
a data efetiva do segundo leilão, o devedor
tem preferência para arrematar aquele bem.
E aí, como é que vai ser a
preferência para ele arrematar aquele bem?
E ele vai pagar só o que ele
estava devendo antes da consolidação da propriedade?
Não.
Ele vai ter que pagar o valor total
do que ele ainda estava devendo, mais o
valor dos encargos que incidiram naquela dívida.
Vai ter que pagar o valor do ITBI
que o credor pagou para consolidar a propriedade
em seu nome.
Então, na prática, é muito difícil que um
devedor exerça esse direito de preferência.
Por quê?
Porque se o devedor não teve como pagar
só as parcelas que ele estava devendo até
a consolidação da propriedade, como é que depois,
de uma hora para outra, ele vai arrumar
dinheiro para pagar todo o valor da dívida
de uma vez?
Se ele estava devendo, inicialmente, 3 parcelas de
2 mil reais, por exemplo, 6 mil reais,
e o total da dívida seria 200 mil
reais, como é que do nada, em 30
dias, ele vai conseguir 200 mil reais?
É muito difícil que o devedor exerça esse
direito de preferência.
Mas esse direito de preferência está regulado em
lei.
É vontade da lei.
Então, o devedor tem que ser notificado da
data do primeiro e do segundo leilão para,
caso ele queira, ele exerça esse direito de
preferência dele de arrematar um imóvel.
E aí, voltando só para finalizar, caso o
imóvel não seja arrematado no primeiro leilão, ele
segue para o segundo leilão.
Caso ele não seja arrematado no segundo leilão,
o credor vai ter que fazer uma carta
de quitação daquela dívida para o devedor.
Ou seja, aconteceu o segundo leilão, ninguém arrematou
aquele bem, o credor vai liberar o devedor
daquela dívida.
Ele vai fazer uma carta de quitação, falando
que aquele devedor não deve mais nada a
ele.
Aquele devedor está livre daquela dívida.
Então, ele está livre da dívida, mas também
está sem o imóvel.
Esse imóvel definitivamente é do banco e, a
partir do segundo leilão, o banco pode fazer
o que ele quiser com o imóvel.
Vender pelo preço que ele quiser aquele imóvel,
porque ele cumpriu os requisitos da lei, que
é a realização do primeiro e do segundo
leilão.
E, a partir daquele momento, o bem é
completamente dele e ele pode vender aquele bem
da forma como ele preferir, com o preço
que ele preferir.
É isso que a gente vai estudar na
próxima aula, o que acontece com o imóvel
quando ele não é arrematado em primeiro e
em segundo leilão.